tre ore per sistemare una telecamera 5
milioni e mezzo dai signori questo sarà
l'anno della patente io ve lo dico 2020
io ve lo giuro e io ho la patente Ok
promesso
Pronto
come sempre vuoi sapere come ho studiato
Questa è la mia tecnica studiata cioè è
una tecnica accurata che ho utilizzato
anche alle superiori vai
oh oh
Eccolo eccolo là Eccolo là ci siamo ci
siamo niente Buongiorno
a contro ogni mia singola legge mentale
poterti dire che sono promosso perché
anche l'ultima volta sono riuscita
Quindi per me dirti che sono promosso è
un'eresia perché poi non è mai così però
io reputo impossibile che io sia stato
bocciato perché era una domanda
veramente Adesso li faccio vedere
ragazzi non ci credo adesso vi faccio
vedere i miei quiz della patente con la
mia app di quiz della patente no che
quella della tua scuola Allora questa è
la Ok sì Allora adesso vi faccio vedere
questa cosa tutto il mio allenamento
nelle ultime due settimane ha dato
questi risultati qua Allora questi sono
quelli vecchi da qua da qua ha iniziato
il periodo di studio da qua
serpente Verdi tutte verdi e queste sono
molto erano molto più difficili di
quelle che mi è capitato adesso quindi
non è possibile non è possibile se sono
bocciato veramente la mia vita una
barzelletta e lo è già basta basta basta
basta fare quiz basta Basta mi sono
rotto il cazzo
sono a 40 40 45 di fila ok azzeccate E
questa era molto più facile di queste 45
quindi non può essere
mi è arrivato il messaggio se sono stato
promosso o meno e non lo so ancora
perché
questo è il messaggio
Fabietto patente mi scrive lo apriamo
insieme dai
mo' son cazzi miei che devo farti
guidare tre errori promosso
[Musica]
adesso che si fa
Ah boh non lo so non sono mai arrivato a
questo punto signori allora siamo in un
momento storico perché stiamo andando a
fare la prima guida una volta che passi
la teoria tu devi fare almeno sei guide
con la macchina per per prendere la
patente per il buongiorno Che mi
accompagnerà in questa avventura
incredibile ovviamente Lorenzo non è che
si mette a fare la patente in un momento
storico che è tutto tranquillo no
coronavirus
Umbrella Corporation però meglio perché
c'è meno gente in giro Cioè quindi meno
morbido
imparo bene ma chi se ne frega
L'importante
importantissimo trovare utilissimo
ritorno indietro
Va bene Si comincia malissimo Non
rompere Prima
Uh addirittura la seconda non rompere
[Musica]
parcheggio in retro tra i One
sette anni e mezzo oggi mettiamo la
parola fine quanto me la sto tirando
è il momento dell'esame Mi stavo
ripassando la le precedenze che non mi
ricordo più se dal perché al momento
dell'esame poi non ti ricordi a destra a
sinistra la precedenza sai quando in
matematica Fai 2 + 2 perché ovviamente
si vedrà
come dice uno dei miei personaggi degli
anime preferiti
[Risate]
Spero di Guidare col mio stand amico mio
ciao ciao
Com'è finita dov'è
Allora ragazzi Il problema è stato il
problema è stato singolare perché mentre
ovviamente non ho potuto portare Perché
non si può portare Giampiero a
registrare mentre facevo Però il
problema Il problema più grosso è stato
ehm
tra l'altro è belli Cioè tu non hai idea
di quanto questo avere questo pezzo di
di plastica sia tutta la mia vita a
ruota attorno a questo pezzo di plastica
Cioè negli ultimi sette anni
che cazzo ridete fatto è che mentre
Guida no È stata un'esperienza
incredibile Praticamente il tipo mi ha
fatto delle domande prima di guidare
guidare non c'è stato problema è che è
incredibile però prima di salire in
macchina tipo mi ha fatto delle domande
sono state queste Quali sono i liquidi
che bisogna controllare la macchina
motore ok acqua acqua acqua
un liquido che devi controllare qual è
che cazzo ne so io ho paura che non mi
facesse entrare in macchina per questo e
invece poi mi è venuto in mente un'altra
cosa di tergicristalli Eh sì ok va bene
Non devo prendere la macchina perché non
so il liquido dei tre giri sa Dai dai È
stato incredibile bene Adesso sono
emozionato Scusate eh
Adesso manca la macchina Sostanzialmente
però però prendi un cazzo grosso
l'abbiamo fatto quindi vabbè allora non
so quando vedrete questo video perché il
discorso è stato che abbiamo un miliardo
di Clip da mettere insieme di tutto
questo percorso del 2020 questo video
uscirà nel 2022 Eh però spero che questa
Odissea della patente vi sia piaciuta
a me No adesso vado a buttare tutte le
cose che avevo da studiare pertanto non
mi ricordo più tra 5 minuti buon buon
esatto ciao
[Musica]